m
[Musique]
c'est tout le sien
[Applaudissements]
on peut remonter
c'est en vol
et encore une enfant
je suis envolé
[Applaudissements]
enfin
donc vous avez tous une ardoise devant
vous je vais vous donner une action
affaires ou une vérité à dire pour sa
vérité vous devrez tous répondre à la
question sur vos ardoise pour chaque
d'art cas vous devrez tout s'est clos le
nom de celui qui devra exécuter le gage
ok d'accord qui va l'annoncer il a calé
l'eau avec un yack 15 avec ariane hockey
me connaissez yakalelo cessa yakalelo ya
qu un tel club
quel visage il kiev kay gee maarten à
limeyrat m
je vous remercie comme il ya toujours un
petit peu de danse de cette émission
ouais mais avec un accès rapide à ces
quatre éléments terre de yaka les lots
le a mis le petit doigt m'a attaqué
j'ai obtenu un conseil chez vous si vous
faites attaquer sachez que même l'homme
le plus fort le monde ne peut rien faire
sur lui cassent le genou rodhouse ça va
hélas là je suis là et là celui qu à ce
genou hélas après jeu après jeu nous
fait plaisir
à noter près patienter près je crois je
chauffe pour danser mais comment le yak
veulent ils auraient pu le prendre il
peut le prendre pas les par l'école non
on fait avec la fallait aller attention
musique c'est parti
jean suffocante
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les gosses c'est le cas avec le mec qui
kiffe le plus élevé et la gym organise
une corde il m'a dit dans le dos
[Applaudissements]
et enfin
à troyes s'est même pas échauffé
robespierre hockey
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]